we cross our fingers for luck we've been
doing it for centuries
but why originally the gesture needed
two people it was an ancient pagan
custom for people to cross fingers with
each other they believed their wishes
would be kept safe at the point where
their fingers crossed until they came
true this idea of capturing good fortune
also explains the practice of tying
string around a finger for Celts and
anglo-saxons
it would literally tether good luck to a
person the gesture also has roots within
Christianity when faced with persecution
early Christians would cross their
fingers to invoke the power of Christ's
crucifixion and in a secret handshake
they would cross fingers with fellow
Christians before gathering together in
safety for mass the handshake made the
Christian symbol of the Ichthus or sign
of the fish it's thought that Christians
who were persecuted would cross their
fingers to absolve themselves from the
lies they told to their tormentors and
that is why we cross our fingers behind
our back when making a promise we don't
intend to keep in England in the 16th
century people cross their fingers to
protect themselves from evil coughs and
sneezes in a 1787 book of popular
superstitions it recommended keeping
your fingers crossed
after walking under a ladder until you
see a dog
but it is the gestures association with
good luck that has stood the test of
time a recent University College of
London study found that crossing fingers
confuses the way our brains processed
pain signals actually reducing painful
sensations and if that's true then that
would be a bit of good luck for everyone
[Music]